vergiss vielleicht auch Fisch wir machen
heute einen backfisch-burger der ein
bisschen geiler ist der Fisch kommt
gleich erst beginnen wir mit der Soße
das ist eine Tartar Soße und wir müssen
einfach alles was ihr hier seht klein
schnippeln Gewürzgurken Schnittlauch
Dill und zu guter Letzt Kapern das ganze
mischen wir jetzt mit Gurkenwasser der
zeste und im Saft einer Zitrone jetzt
noch mal oder dazu umrühren und fertig
ist unsere Soße machen wir jetzt den
Ausbackteig für unseren Fisch 400 g Mehl
Cayennepfeffer Knoblauchgranulat und
weißer Pfeffer jetzt ein Ei und ganz
wichtig 330 ml Bier und alles glatt
verrühren schnell das Bann in Butter
antosten wenn die Band so aussehen sind
sie fertig gehen wir jetzt unseren Fisch
das ist Kabeljau in den Bierteig dass er
von allen Seiten bedeckt ist dann können
wir ihn auch schon auf die große Reise
schicken in die Fritteuse
und weiß den Teig schon hier mache ich
noch ein paar Union Rings dazu wow
fertig ist unser Fisch nehmen wir
unseren Fisch da ziehen ihn und
übergießen unser Band mit der
tatarsusoße Zeit den König zu grünen
lass uns probieren